coming our way right now on the rich
eisen show one of our favorites from the
worldwide leader in sports uh one of
very few people can pull off a two shot
with tom brady quite like this man
uh he is jeff darlington back here on
the show how are you jeff
i'm great i really enjoy the what's in
the box section
but you know it is true though like i
think everybody has you know when you
get that box from your parents that
they're like you know what i bestow this
trash onto you
i don't know how do i how do i throw
this stuff out jeff i'm a pack rat too
so but put it in your car you put in
your your attic and someday you you pass
it on to
chris brockman
here we go
chris chris is going to get all sorts of
stuff for his child i'm excited uh hey
when did you sit down with brady
jeff
recently but not uh not this week okay
okay so um he was not he was not
interested in sitting down this week
yeah i could pretty much
figure that one out so
um
what did you talk with him about uh for
this week then because i'm sure you know
whenever you did sit down with him this
game was coming down the pike this is
this is it so yeah yeah no i mean i i
think um i think the thing that i
i took away
that i was most fascinated by was
the fact that he
has he's really visualizing exactly what
this experience is going to be like um
what i
i thought he would go down the cliche
road of you know i'm sure it'll be
emotional and
but but instead he was like oh i know
exactly what this is going to be like i
know what that what they're going to say
i know how they're going to prepare
i know what the wind is going to be like
and and when he's saying that i'm
thinking
he doesn't say anything without thinking
about it
and this is just my interpretation i'm
not suggesting i'm not trying to put
words in his mouth here but what he's
saying and i'm thinking he is absolutely
sending a message right up to new
england right now saying he's coming you
know in in the in the most subtle
possible way he's saying i'm going to be
there and i know exactly what i'm
getting into that that was my takeaway
from it well my my only
frame of reference is whatever i've gone
through personally jeff and you know
you're working where i used to work and
um
and uh you know things have worked out
for me
um you know and i feel like i'm you know
in a better position lifewise
professional wise but you know
i still have
tremendous feelings for the place at
espn and the people i met and i just you
know just talked to berman for a podcast
and you know i i i it's it's all great
but i i definitely when i go on the air
even 18 years later i want to win you
know while on nfl network and i'm just
wondering though like
even winning a championship i mean even
spiking the football
like he was able to do in front of the
whole country
right i mean
still doesn't even compare to winning
sunday night i would still deep down
imagine
i think so too um i understand
the degree to which brady is trying to
publicly for instance yesterday during
his press conference
um be as dismissive as possible of the
hype um
but
you know talking to people around him
i think that i i truly do believe
that that is the mentality he's taking
not because he doesn't want to go up
there and absolutely sump
sump the patriots
but
because he knows that the best chance he
has of doing that
is to treat this game
exactly as he treats all games which is
not to go overboard not to overthink it
and
uh and i give him credit for it i think
that he realizes if he can go up there
and just perform like he
believes he can
that he can celebrate it
after and forever if he gets that win
jeff darlington here on the rich eisen
show and then i guess to put a a fine
point on it while i'm still comparing
myself to tom brady
um
well when i when i've interviewed brady
in the past certainly in person i'll be
honest i make sure that i i um
i eat right in the week before uh i
moisturize i got the best suit i mean
what about you jeff how was that i mean
so it's so um
i don't even want to say this because
it's just going to
make the eyes roll across the country
but you just you're looking in the guy
you're looking at the guy's face when
he's talking to you and you
you just sort of you're like what what
am i doing right
now but i remember also like talking to
my my producers the night before the
interview and kind of saying like hey
look tom brady makes you feel
uh and i i know people are rolling their
eyes if you're not a tom brady offender
just being nominated
it's the truth jeff because he he makes
you feel
like you're one of the guys right and he
will make you
he will he will make take you off guard
and you'll be like wow he's such a great
guy but i i reminded the
producers and the people that would be
on the set that don't let that detract
from the fact that we are interviewing
babe ruth
that that this is a living active legend
in front of us and
it deserves the type of
of
of uh respect that that we need to give
this interview because it's it's one of
those things where he is a
likeable person in that moment but he's
also i mean this isn't as much as people
don't want to we're living history when
we're watching him play football right
now
yeah and then you know the two shot for
me uh you know i was wearing a great
suit and it looked like a burlap sack
whenever they took the two shot you know
and uh you gotta you gotta definitely
put your best food on i mean we're just
making people just nodding no i don't i
don't care i'm just this is we're
spitting truth jeff this is the honest
uh truth so
um jeff darlington here on the rich
eisen show has uh
has matt nagy named a starter for the
bears did i miss that amongst the hoopla
the bell the belichick brady
seth wickersham hoopla did we miss that
i'm in i i am in one track mode right
now i know that but involves tom brady
i don't think he has
like so what's
what's going on in there well because
dalton is do i understand that dalton
can play on sunday
i don't we honestly like we're we're
literally hitting the old google machine
right now jeff
we're not seeing anything so andy dalton
jeff was limited on wednesday
and uh fields did practice yesterday
with the though he's dealing with a hand
yeah you know what's funny though is
that like i actually thought this this
was kind of playing out not perfectly in
the sense that
the game was absolutely awful but
that matt maggie could get justin fields
in the game
and be able to go back to andy dalton
without making this like a two-uh
fitzpatrick deal from last year like he
can go back to dawn be like i told you
guys when he's healthy he's got the job
back now i understand it's all facade
and eventually we need to see justin
fields
in in
in better form than we saw in last week
but i do think that this
this is a better scenario than
than having to go back to dalton because
fields isn't isn't playing but why is
bill laser [ __ ] bill laser uh you know i
guess they decided i i need a guy
uh
calling plays with a freaking laser you
know so
i mean what
you know what i'm saying like that's a
weird deal it is like the coach is going
to make the decisions he's making the
decisions and he was brought in to call
the plays and he wins coach of the year
because he's calling the plays and
dialing it up for trubisky and then it
doesn't work out with your biscuit and
then we'll go to false and trubisky's
gone and then we're going to draft
justin fields and he's going to decide
who to start and then it fields his game
and then the day after you know the week
after fields gets sacked nine times yep
it's the play calling now is that just
him his way of taking the pressure off
of the kid
or or saying you know laser you you you
might do a better job i need to focus on
the defense or like i don't know the
administration i don't that one i just
don't get that one that part of the
scary part of all of this
for bears fans is that when you have a
situation where the head coach is so
clearly on the hot seat and so too by
the way is the general manager
decisions start to get made not for the
best interest of necessarily the player
but the best interest of
self-preservation and i i think that
maggie has tried to do a good job of of
trying to say look justin field is not
ready yet
um
but but at the same time every decision
that he now makes we're all going to be
like well is that just because you're
trying to keep your job or is this
actually
uh the best situation to put the bears
in
jeff darlington here on the rich eisen
show um i honestly i would you know
i would be bringing it up if it wasn't
my show that kind of sparked it
but down there in south florida we had
um
trent dilfer on the program and i asked
him about tua since he's been you know
with
us since the elite 11 years and he's
been a guy that every single time you
come on the show uh he's kind of our tua
whisperer he he was uh coaching him up
prior to the draft after his surgery and
just asking him about you know the the
tua
um i guess indifference sometimes and
the two of hate as well yeah um and his
response was well it looks like they got
a good
situation around him roster wise and
charlie frye calling the plays and
everyone's like well he's not the
offensive coordinator actually and
so what is
the the deal and who is actually calling
the plays down in south florida for the
dolphins that's a good question i i i
think that this was sort of the i'm not
trying to steer around your answer too
much but i kind of have to because
this is sort of the uh the downside of
having co-offensive coordinators and why
this
also seems kind of so suspicious um i
can tell you he's not calling the plays
chang gayley and he took all the heat
last year right to his um underwhelming
performance so
the problem for tua is
um if that continues if you can't if you
can't turn the corner soon now you've
changed offensive coordinators you put
the players around him
and and unfortunately the blame is going
to fall squarely on his shoulders
whether that's
fair whether he's had enough time to
develop or not and as long as desean
watson is not on a commission
commissioner's exempt list or
um or or having his um
his
case
handled in a way that that makes him
unavailable whether as a football player
or as a citizen in the society right
um it's entirely possible that this
something's on the table for
for october like how how much does this
bear watching this month before the
trade deadline in the first couple of
days of of november
well certainly significant and not not
not only that but you know what what's
happening with the eagles and jalen
hurts and and seeing what happens if
week one was a better indicator of what
we're going to see from him or
wait three so suddenly
you know i desean has has made clear
that that he'll wave his his um train
clause to go to the dolphins and it
doesn't appear that he
do the same for the eagles but
if the texans were sitting there saying
we get five first round you know if the
price just starts going up
they're gonna be more reluctant to just
do what watson wants so
the more suitors that become available
the more intriguing this absolutely gets
and it does feel like
as this season progresses and we see
some
some maybe maybe more mediocre
quarterback play than we expected desean
watson will be absolutely a name on the
list
uh on the tip of every tongue in every
fan base across the league so i send you
on to your friday sir what do you think
happened sunday night what's the view
what
occurs wait
i i mean i'm inclined to think that
so i just don't know that
matt jones has been in really big
moments
and i i hope that they're explaining to
them how electric this is going to feel
because this is going to be a massive
moment no matter what
these teams want to think it's almost
like when you see a player go into the
super bowl and he's like you know i'm
just going to treat this like any other
game well it's not any other game and
sunday night will not be any other game
i agree i know i i mean do you think
they stopped the game
when he when he when brady passes breeze
breeze is going to be there i mean do
you think brady wants any part of that
and if he doesn't don't you think the
patriots would stop the game just for
that alone he told me that he felt like
he's going to be prepared for everything
but he also did say now i know that
they're going to try to throw some
things
in there
that i that i won't necessarily expect i
honestly think like what that i just i
mean that like i think that bill
belichick would be
is
strategic enough about all these things
that he would be willing
to do whatever he can pomp and
circumstance and otherwise
to do to try to throw brady off his game
i i do not think that this is i think he
will use every single potential
advantage if that means stopping the
game
to to recognize him i could totally see
that happening and i could totally see
bernie being like
son of a you know
well i mean belichick was asked
specifically about that today in his
final media i assumed final i mean the
guy does make himself of quite available
for an nfl head coach
um he he said he was asked today about
stopping the game and he said he did not
know what the protocol is don't you
think
that there's not a single thing that
goes up on that video board about brady
that doesn't get run by the coach's
office at some point right this week i
think i think everything is i think
every single thing is getting run by
them from
who's getting tickets who's on the
sideline i think that he is going to
have his hand in everything that's just
me talking that's just my history of
knowing the way bill belichick operates
but in this game in this setting in this
environment he's going to do whatever he
can to make sure he has the advantage
because i'm again if i'm the crafts i
would want to pay tribute to brady i i
would want to do that right but you
can't do that
without disturbing your coach's
preparation and because the last thing
you want is to have your coach surprised
by anything yeah but what if you go what
if you think about it the other way with
belichick's like i want to show him with
as much praise as i can i want this guy
to be emotional
i mean i can see that i could see that
being in that the judo flip too and
again this is coming from nowhere we're
just
shooting the bull as i say
but i could totally see bill belichick
being like let's throw the guy a parade
well the one to do that would be the way
to do that is if you know when he when
he passes the record that bill
somebody on the patriot staff gets a
bouquet of flowers and hands it to bill
who walks it out to tom and has somebody
and then they they quickly take some
pictures you know together terrible you
know on the field and smile and then
just starting brady's like what the hell
was that like that one for all of this
that would that would totally throw him
off his game completely and like it's
third and four right he just completed a
two yard pass to pass breeze let's stop
the game
and bill's the one who runs out like and
and it's like they make him like miss
america they they throw him but put a tr
on him
yeah the tribute video and it's only 168
yards so that'll happen like halfway
through the first quarter right through
the first 15 scripted you know sorry
sorry left witch your first 15 scripted
hold up let's go
like coming to america roll the red
carpet out to the 50-yard line let's get
some pedals thrown down last one for you
last one for you jeff last one for you
let's say the patriots win the coin toss
what do you think do you think he takes
the ball and hands it to mack jones
first or lets tom have the stage first
what happens let's say the patriots win
the toss
what happens i think he wants mac jones
out there first i think so too
let's go up three nothing let's go up
seven nothing
right
yeah but i don't want i don't want mac
jones feeling that energy yeah or but
then you know you're opening yourself up
to pull the pull the the patriot which
is give brady the ball before and after
the half you don't want that either you
want that for your guy think about it
oh who knows
who knows better than what brady can do
right before and after a half than than
the man
it's like are we you can't pull it's you
it's me that's that's my thing it's you
it's not you it's me like you know like
that's you can't do that that's my thing
like honestly like anything you can do i
can do better all right the whole deal
i i look we might be overthinking this
and i will of course do so until the
ball is kicked off
thanks for the call jeff appreciate it
that's jeff darlington everybody right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here